Finally, you're ready
to launch your cluster.
On the name node,
format the file system.
Then star hdfs.
Since the name known as connecting
to the data node for the first time,
it might ask you if you
want to continue connecting.
Say yes.
Sometimes it might hang
without another prompt.
Just type in yes again, and get going.
You can check that your node are running
by going to the named nodes web
interface in a browser.
You can get there with the name node
public host name on port five zero zero
seven zero.
Okay, this is what I see.
And here,
we see we have three live nodes.
These are the data nodes.
Now Start yarn.
And finally, start the jobbers.
And finally,
start the job history server.
Now you can see the daemons running.
On the name node enter JPS.
Here you see the JobHistoryServer
SecondaryNameNode NameNode and
a ResourceManager.
These are all daemone that are running
on the name node computer.
And on the data node, you see
a NodeManager and the DataNode daemone.